luke here with the outdoor boys youtube
channel and i'm here clearing a 300 foot
strip of land to make a road and a
clearing so i'm going to take this
opportunity to show you guys all the
best ways to remove a stop
so the first method for removing a tree
stump is my absolute favorite but it
requires some forethought you've got to
start planting before you knock the tree
down and like most methods it requires a
little bit of digging we want to find
the main roots and expose those to the
air
once you find and expose some roots then
you start cutting them but don't use
your nice axe for this because you'll
dull the crap out of your blade
next we're going to throw a rope up as
high into the tree as we can to get as
much leverage as we can the tree trunk
is like a giant cheater bar and the
higher up you attach the rope the more
leverage you get when you pull
i've done this a number of times and
often after you've finished digging all
you need is a little tug on the rope to
make the whole tree topple over but this
one's got a bit of a funky root ball and
it's holding a lot tighter so i'm going
to use a come along
look at the size of that root ball
whoo
well it ain't easy but if you're looking
to get the whole stump out this is one
of the best methods
[Applause]
[Music]
took a lot of doing
but we got it pulled out of the way that
thing weighs about 200 pounds
if you need to get 100 of that stump out
of the ground
then this is probably one of the best
ways to do it next we're going to take
out this tree and remove the stump using
fire and there's a right way and a wrong
way to do this all right we've got to
stop and most importantly it's dead dry
wood so it's going to burn up nice and
easily now if we build a bonfire around
this it's going to burn downward very
very slowly if we can dig under it just
a little bit and build a fire underneath
the stump it's going to burn up so much
quicker
you just got to get the base of the fire
low enough that the heat is going up the
stump instead of down the stump
[Music]
there we go only thing left of the stump
is this root
and this root
and you can see it got down deep well
burning out a stump takes a whole lot
less energy than digging it out by hand
but it took us about 10 hours of burning
and we ended up using the entire tree
plus a little extra as fuel to burn out
that stump so it takes
a lot of fuel additionally this isn't a
safe thing to do in some places because
of fire hazard and there's a lot of laws
about where and when you can do open
burnings also you really need an old dry
stump for this to work well if you try
to burn out a green stump it's going to
take a lot longer all right guys i have
here in my hand the extractagator the
big daddy model and this tool is meant
to pull out trees or bushes
root and all and it does trees up to
three inches supposedly so we're going
to show you how it works and give it a
little test
got a two inch tree here
you just push the bar forward stick the
jaws around lean the bar back and it
grips the trunk really sharp
turn it around
oh
pop that little devil out in no time
there's a little bit of root left but
man it got almost everything out that
worked great all right i'm gonna try
this thing out on some of these small
stumps
there you go
oh that just barely fits
look at that good job
that thing beats a shovel and a saw any
day all right so if you guys want to buy
the extractagator i'll put a link down
in the video description below where i
got it
all right here's a typical come along
that you get at harbor freight or home
depot and the rating on this one i
believe is 2 500 pounds
which seems like a lot of weight
but it's uh
not as much as you'd think and if you're
going to use brute force to pull out a
stump make sure you use chains or nylon
straps don't use rope because rope will
stretch and if it snaps it'll come at
you like a giant rubber band chains and
nylon straps don't stretch that much
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
only works if you have an anchor point
that's stronger than the stump that
you're trying to remove additionally i'm
trying to pull this stump straight this
way takes a lot more force to pull the
stump sideways than it does to pull it
up
a lot of people try doing this with
their pickup truck instead of a
come-along and i've seen it where the
chain comes undone and it snaps back and
takes out the back window or the
tailgate of the pickup truck when you
get close to ripping the stump out it'll
start to wiggle like a tooth
and this thing isn't even close to
wiggling yet i don't think we're gonna
get it with this setup this stump is
only maybe seven inches wide
and 2 000 pounds of pressure ain't
enough to pull it out sideways
we got the same thing
except now we've got a tire underneath
the chain closest to the stump we want
out and that's pulling the chain up at a
45 degree angle
which minimizes the amount of force it
takes to remove the stump
green stumps take a lot more force to
pull out than rotten old dead stumps and
these are all very green stumps so i'm
not sure if this is even gonna pull out
but let's give it a try see what happens
now you can see what this is doing to my
spare tire it's just about to pop it so
i can't go any higher this thing is
still in there rock solid for this
technique to work you either need a
rotten stump or you need a stump that's
been dug out a little bit i mean to just
brute force rip out a seven inch stump
takes a lot of force and this isn't
going to cut it
[Music]
look what happened to the come along man
that's how much pressure it took to pop
that thing out even with the roots cut
man that is all splumpus
so that tells you how much pressure it
took just to pull up this seven inch
dump after we cut the roots so if you
think you could just take a logging
chain and wrap it around a stump and
yank it out with your truck you're
taking a big gamble with your
transmission and your chassis and all
that stuff man
brute force yoinking out a stump is hard
to do fyi sticking your chainsaw in the
dirt like that destroys your chainsaw
blades that one was on its way out
anyway so i kind of did it but you might
want to use an axe instead
now i know a lot of you guys are
wondering luke why don't you just blow
up those stumps
and you can there's a product called
tanonite which is a target practicing
explosive and you can buy it from
cabela's in other places and have it
delivered to your door and it's a
two-part explosive that you mix together
you dig a hole under the stump you put
about
five pounds of it underneath there and
boom you blow that thing up
now there's a couple problems first off
it's a bit of a legal gray area i'm in
my state it's a serious felony to have
bomb making equipment and bomb making
materials and
it's a little bit of a gray area whether
or not tananite classifies as bomb
making materials and i'm a criminal
defense attorney by trade and i
researched the issue and i'm telling you
it's unclear so i'm not going to mess
with it it takes a lot of explosives and
a lot of digging to blow up a stop
because you got to put the explosives
underneath the stump and then it wants
to just blow the dirt out around the
stump without blowing up the stump so
you've gotta you put like five pounds
plus of explosives and five pounds of
tan a night will probably run you like
eighty to a hundred dollars so you know
it's not cheap it's might get you in
jail so before you try blowing anything
up definitely think twice and check your
local loss well all the techniques i've
been showing you so far are great if you
only have one or two stumps to remove
but if you're like me and have 50 to 100
stumps to remove
you're gonna want this
[Music]
if you want to remove stumps quickly and
have fun doing it it's hard to beat a
backhoe even the largest dumps come out
pretty easily and you can use the
backhoe to fill up the holes left behind
by the stumps as well but it costs about
500 a day and it takes a little bit of
finesse and room to be able to operate
one of these pieces of equipment
a good alternative is a stump grinder
they can be as small as a rototiller or
as big as a bobcat they cost between 100
to 400 a day and they can grind up at a
very large stump in about an hour stump
grinders are really easy to use but you
do have to do some prep work and digging
you have to cut this down flush to the
ground and then you want to remove any
soil or rocks from around the stump to
avoid damaging the grinder stump
grinders generally don't get the roots
but they will remove the stump to about
two to four inches below the soil
surface
if you have a dry old brittle stump you
can use a chainsaw to make some plunge
cuts into the stump in a checkerboard
pattern and then use a sledge hammer and
some wedges to break the stump up and
take it out this method is still a lot
of manual labor and it'll trash your
chainsaw blade if the blade touches the
dirt or rocks but it works pretty well
on dry brittle old stumps there's many
products online that claim to help
stumps biodegrade or break down and i've
seen videos of people trying to use
epsom salts however i've not seen any
evidence that these things actually work
and it takes many years if not decades
for a stump to biodegrade
well guys i hope this video will help
you get that stump out a little bit
easier save you some heartache if you
guys want to see more videos from the
outdoor boys youtube channel don't
forget to click subscribe and check out
some of our other stuff we have tons of
outdoor adventures including survival
camping and travel adventures don't
forget to click subscribe we put out new
videos every saturday morning i'll see
you guys next saturday morning
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every saturday morning and hit
that bell button and you'll get
notifications thanks for watching
[Music]